Well today I'm really glad
to get to share something with you
that I've been working on
for the past 15 years.
But more importantly,
something that could become
the first specimen
of an entire new industry
that we might find all around the planet
over the next decades.
Think of it as something
like the very first smartphone.
Still quite clumsy and quite expensive,
but of transformative technology.
Smartphones have changed
the way how we communicate.
This, I hope,
could change the way
we deal with global warming.
This is Orca.
This is the first worldwide commercial
direct air capture and storage plant.
It is in Iceland,
and it is an industrial plant
that extracts CO2 out of ambient air.
We have operated now
for more than one year.
It costs more than 10 million
dollars to build Orca.
And its modules,
those eight boxes
that we call CO2 collectors,
they are designed to extract a bit more
than 10 tons of carbon dioxide
from the air every day.
It sounds quite expensive.
However, when thinking about cost,
we should keep in mind one thing.
There is one thing that we cannot buy,
and that is time.
And we need to be quite fast here.
So that is why
Orca is not there to demonstrate costs.
Orca is there to show in the field,
out there, in the weather,
that the plant is operating,
and Orca is working.
So the next step for us at Climeworks
and for all the other
companies in the field
is now going forward,
improving the technology,
scaling it up from tens to hundreds
to millions of tons capacity.
And as we go ahead and we scale it up,
with every new plant going online,
we'll have efficiencies going up
and we'll have costs going down.
Now, how does it work?
In the case of Orca,
we have fans mounted to the CO2 collectors
that draw air through them.
Inside there is a filter material
that we call sorbent,
a highly porous material.
And as the air pulls through it,
the CO2 is bound at the surface
of this material.
Think of it as a sponge
that sucks up water in its pores.
We do that for a certain time until the
material is filled with used CO2,
it is saturated.
And we close the modules,
we heat them up
to around 100 degrees Celsius,
and we can extract
concentrated CO2 from them.
The good thing is
that the main energy input
that we need for that process
is low temperature heat
at around 100 degrees Celsius.
And it can entirely be powered
by renewable energy.
Now that looks quite easy
at first glance, right?
And indeed, the process
behind that is quite simple.
However, when it comes
to implementing that into reality
in the field out there
with the purpose of having a plant
that is constantly operating,
24/7, reliably,
then it becomes quite challenging.
Let me give you two examples
why it is a challenge
to capture and remove CO2 from the air.
First of all,
there is not a lot of CO2 in the air.
We're currently at around 420 ppm.
That means one molecule out of 2,500
molecules in the air around us
is CO2.
That's not a lot.
And that means to extract
only one ton of CO2 from the air,
we need to filter around
two million cubic meters of air.
That's about 800 Olympic swimming pools.
And there's another way of picturing that,
which I personally find quite puzzling.
Imagine one of these filters
with an inlet area
of one meter by one meter.
And the amount of air,
like, think of it as a block of air
that you have to push
through that filter inlet
to take just one ton
of CO2 out of the air,
is 2,000 kilometers long.
Another example why this is a challenge
is that it is not so easy to find good,
actually, the best sorbent materials,
which are both high-performing
and which can prevail outside
there in the field with a long life.
Now, in this next picture,
you see Christoph and myself,
cofounders of Climeworks,
in the very early days
of Climeworks, working on that.
The very first sorbents,
we produced them with our own hands,
such as you would do your laundry
if you didn't have a washing machine.
We set some sorbents on fire,
and we produced hundreds of samples
in the past 10 years.
Looking forward,
thousands of more will come, very likely.
Now, this is one way of doing it.
We are doing that in our company,
but many others are doing it.
There are companies out there, start-ups,
more established companies
and researchers and scientists.
And that is a good thing
because the challenge
ahead of us is immense.
Now let's step back
and look at the big picture.
So where does this kind of technology fit
into our overall fight
against climate change?
And it's important
that first and foremost,
the most important thing
we need to do is, and will always stay,
the drastic reduction of emissions
of greenhouse gases.
Without that,
we will have no chance of ever meeting
any of our climate goals.
Then in a second step,
it will be important that we can all
ramp up the capacity
of extracting and removing
CO2 from the atmosphere.
Now, when thinking about the latter,
so far I've spoken about technology,
but we shouldn't forget that also,
nature offers several solutions
to extract carbon from the air,
such as forests and oceans.
And one element that is very important
will be doubling down
on these methods offered by nature,
enhancing them and protecting them.
That is important.
However, will it be sufficient to rely
only on nature-based carbon sinks?
Very likely not.
Trees need time to grow
and forests need space,
and there is simply
just not enough area available
to plant entire continents of new forests,
which we would need
in order to capture many billions of tons
of CO2 from the atmosphere.
And therefore,
besides preserving all these
nature-based solutions and enhancing them,
it will be very important
to scale up technology-based solutions
for large-scale carbon removal
from the atmosphere.
Now, I often get asked if you build
direct air capture plants
like the one we saw before,
is that a license to continue polluting?
It is clearly not.
Direct air capture is not a silver bullet,
but it is a must-have.
Had we stopped emitting 20, 30 years ago,
or at least substantially
reduced our emissions,
Climeworks and this whole
emerging industry around us
would likely not be here today.
And for the climate,
that would probably
be the better solution.
However, that's not where we are today.
Today, the IPCC has indicated
in their last report
that technology-based solutions
to remove carbon from the air
are a necessity,
and they included it [in] their models.
And that is why this entire industry
that is currently emerging
now needs to double down on moving
from small-scale and relatively expensive
to larger-scale and cheap.
Double down on developing, deploying,
learning and adjusting in the field.
We have to develop markets,
we have to develop policy.
And we have to develop mechanisms
to analyze the CO2 capture
and other technical ways
of removing CO2
that take care of the fact
that by taking CO2
out of the air with machines
and putting it down in the ground
we have one of the most permanent ways
of storing the CO2 away
for millions of years.
Now let’s get back one step,
and let’s get back to today where we are.
And let’s get back to the present,
to what is concrete.
Let's get back to Iceland
and our Orca plant.
I've told you before how these collectors
extract CO2 from the air.
Now, how do we make sure that it really
permanently stays locked away?
For that reason, in Iceland,
we have partnered up
with a company Carbfix
and have developed a method
for permanent carbon storage
through mineralization.
What they do is they take the CO2,
mix it with water,
and inject it into underground volcanic,
so-called basalt rock formations.
That is one of the most abundant stone
or stone material that you find on Earth.
And by doing so,
the CO2 binds with the rock,
it mineralizes,
and it literally turns into stone
within two years,
hundreds of meters underground.
The good thing about that method
is that it is very tangible,
and it's very easy to understand.
And for that purpose, I've brought
this rock sample here for you.
That is taken actually from a drill core
of a basalt rock formation
hundreds of meters underground.
And what you can see here,
that's a black rock,
which is the black basalt rock,
containing some white crystals.
And these crystals are CO2
turned into stone underground
and locked away.
(Applause)
Now I explained to you
one method of doing this.
There are several other methods out there.
There are several other techniques,
other technologies.
But the important thing about it
is that this thing is out there.
It's in practice, it's operating,
and we are learning from it.
And that is so essential
for this new industry.
And we have learned a lot, actually.
We have learned how to operate
on hot, dry summer days.
We learned to operate them
in pouring rain.
And we even had to learn
how to operate them on a just normal day.
We had to learn
how to ramp up the Orca plant
immediately after an Icelandic snowstorm.
And this all is what we need
in order to deploy these plants
all over the world.
We should deploy them all over the world
because we do need so many of them.
We can deploy them all over the world
because the air is everywhere around us
and the CO2 is almost
the same concentration
everywhere where we are.
So it doesn't matter
where we capture the CO2.
And for that reason,
and in the spirit of deploying more,
in June of this year
we have announced the next step
on our Climeworks scale-up road map,
which is named Mammoth,
and that is what you see here.
That is a plant which is nine times
larger than the Orca plant,
that will be in Iceland as well.
And the first tons of CO2
will be captured by the end of 2023.
This winter, we will finalize the first
building before the snow starts.
Now there is a big challenge ahead of us.
And actually, you can only really
understand what this challenge is
and really quantify it
if you build these things out there,
make mistakes and learn from them.
So it's a hard problem.
It's not a simple problem to solve,
and there is no easy solution to it.
And without action like this,
there is no solution at all.
And so when I started looking
back at the last 15 years,
what we have been doing,
I'm now looking forward
to the next 15 years that are to come
because that is what we need.
Thank you.
(Applause)